m
[Musique]
les danses d'idriss âge ou de l'escrim
avec les chevaux le spectacle la voie de
l'écuyer chorégraphié par bartabas est
interprété par l'académie équestre de
versailles
elle présente son 21e opus c'est notre
histoire en raconte l'évolution de nos
chevaux là il ya des nouveaux chevaux
les fonderies qu'on voit au début sont
des chevaux qu'on a eu de tout petits à
un an et que là on met en spectacle
maintenant qu'ils ont huit ans donc
c'est vraiment l'évolution n'est le plus
sincère qu'on peut dans ce spectacle
avec ce qu'on vit au quotidien
cette année la promotion est
exclusivement féminine à l'académie les
écuyères ne font pas que de l'équitation
chorale danse ou encore escrime les
disciplines sont variés et permettent la
coordination et la cohésion de l'équipe
c'est une discipline qui les menait
cesse beaucoup de rigueur envers soi
même et en même temps du lâcher prise
donc c'est assez
il ya vraiment un équilibre à trouver
entre la technique est juste l'âme et
les sensations et donc ça à l'académie
comme on pratique d'autres disciplines
artistiques c'est très bien pour
développer ce côté sensibilité
le spectacle est chaque année améliorer
des tableaux sont ajoutés les chevaux et
écuyers se perfectionne au grand plaisir
de ses habitués toujours merveilleux de
venir ici on apprécie le spectacle de
chevaux sont tous magnifiques
il ya toujours des petits plus et des
nouvelles choses qu'on voit et
des différents chevaux et autres et là
on a vu qu'il y avait un cheval qui
était borgne et c'est extraordinaire le
travail qui est fait avec lui le
spectacle est présenté chaque week-end
tout au long de l'année
[Musique]